Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
"Mister Wireless" è un nomignolo
che mi hanno cucito addosso alcuni anni fa
in occasione di quello che è stato
il primo lavoro che abbiamo fatto,
per dimostrare
che si poteva utilizzare tecnologia povera
ma ben fatta, ben dimensionata,
ben organizzata
per portare Internet
laddove Internet non c'è.
Ormai me lo tengo,
perché lo hanno utilizzato i giornali,
lo hanno utilizzato le TV;
ovviamente potete immaginare
quanto mi prendano in giro
gli amici per questo,
ma ormai è così.
Io ho pensato di organizzare
questi dieci minuti di chiacchierata
facendovi vedere come si può
fare ricerca, nel nostro paese,
praticamente senza denaro -
anche perché siamo costretti,
a fare ricerca nel nostro paese,
senza denaro -
e sfogliando un calendario
che comincia nel 2004,
quando, insieme con una persona
che all'epoca era un mio studente,
abbiamo deciso di portare avanti
una realizzazione,
che doveva coronare un sogno,
che era quello di dimostrare
che si poteva lavorare ad alta tecnologia,
con costi molto contenuti
e magari riuscendo anche a fare
delle realizzazioni che avessero
anche una finalità sociale,
una finalità utile,
tenendo conto che la gran parte
dei sistemi di telecomunicazione,
sapete bene,
sono stati inventati invece,
fondamentalmente, principalmente,
almeno all'inizio,
con finalità di tipo militare.
Nel 2004, la foto che c'è di là
non si vede tanto bene,
ma in questo laboratorio
che abbiamo chiamato IXem
è stato fondato a quattro mani
e a quattro zampe.
Le quattro zampe sono quelle
del mio coinquilino,
che era nato l'anno prima
e che mi accompagnava
tutti i sabati in ufficio
perché era piccolo e non avevo intenzione
di lasciarlo da solo a casa;
e le quattro mani sono le due mani mie
e quelle due di Riccardo Stefanelli,
il primo nella foto che rappresenta
i componenti del laboratorio adesso,
Che appunto ci trovavamo
il sabato in laboratorio,
lui stava iniziando a fare
qualche progettino,
qualche piccola intership;
e diciamo che abbiamo condiviso,
fin dall'inizio,
l'idea che era alla base
di quel principio
che vi ho espresso prima.
Come e quando siamo riusciti
a metterla in atto, a metterla in pratica?
È stato agli inizi del 2005,
e l'abbiamo fatto
in quello che io considero
il posto più bello del pianeta,
non perché ci sono nato,
non perché ci vivo, ovviamente no,
che è il comune di Verrua Savoia,
nel Monferrato, quindi
nelle colline piemontesi,
dove nel 2005 - stiamo parlando
di otto anni fa -
non solo non c'era
la connettività a banda larga,
come in tanti posti in Italia all'epoca,
ma nessuno ce la voleva portare,
perché sostenevano che costava troppo
e perché sostenevano
che se avessero fatto una realizzazione,
e portato internet
in quel posto, all'epoca,
poi gli operatori non avrebbero ottenuto
una rendita economica,
così come se l'Enel,
negli anni '20 o negli anni '30,
avesse pensato che si doveva
portare l'elettricità
esclusivamente nelle città,
perché in campagna non avrebbe reso,
o se gli acquedotti
fossero stati costruiti
solo per le città di Roma,
Milano, Torino, Venezia e Firenze,
perché in tutte le altre
non sarebbero potuti
rientrare degli investimenti.
Purtroppo, le telecomunicazioni
si sono sviluppate, in Italia,
troppo recentemente,
quando alcune politiche
di discutibile privatizzazione
avevano ormai rovinato
quello che è il principio di base
e cioè che i servizi
dovrebbero essere portati a tutti
e che la valutazione
della rendita economica dei servizi
dovrebbe essere misurata
su scala nazionale,
e non su una scala locale e contingente.
Nel 2005, il sindaco del mio comune
mi incontra per strada e mi dice:
mi hanno chiesto 30.000 euro
per portare internet qua, come faccio?
Non li ho, se spendo 30. 000 euro
non riesco più ad asfaltare le strade.
Ho detto va bene, proviamo,
facciamo qualcosa noi.
Abbiamo preso dei pezzi in laboratorio,
abbiamo preso quella roba là,
che è un vecchio computer
che non usavamo più per fare simulazioni,
lo abbiamo rielaborato, abbiamo costruito
un codice abbastanza sofisticato,
ma poi alla fine montato su componenti,
vedete lo stato
in cui versava quella roba,
lo abbiamo utilizzato per realizzare
un sistema di ponti di trasmissione,
che fondamentalmente avevano
all'interno dei comuni:
router wireless, come quelli che avete
nelle vostre case.
E aprimmo, nel maggio del 2005,
il primo hot spot -
quelli che adesso vanno di moda,
ma che all'epoca non ce n'erano molti,
soprattutto in campagna -
era il primo aperto, al di fuori
della città di Torino, in Piemonte.
Connettività per tutti,
connettività gratuita:
doveva essere, ovviamente,
un esempio, uno stimolo.
In meno di un mese raggiungemmo 80 persone
che accettavano di andare in piazza -
al freddo, tra l'altro,
perché quel maggio fu pure freddo -
per collegarsi alla rete,
per disporre della connettività .
Quindi qualche cosa si poteva fare
e si poteva fare anche pensando
di lavorare a costo basso
e magari utilizzando
un know-how sofisticato
per realizzare alcune cose.
Per cui la Regione Piemonte
si accorse di noi
e nel 2006 ci diede un piccolissimo
contributo economico,
ma tant'era,
per riuscire a portare avanti un progetto
che prevedeva l'unione
di tutta una serie di istituti scolastici,
ovviamente in posti sfigatissimi,
quindi tra campagna, collina, ecc.,
dove i bambini non avevano
la possibilità di lavorare su internet.
Fu un'esperienza straordinaria,
tutti i miei studenti furono coinvolti;
e la cosa bella era
che quando portammo la connessione
per la prima volta
furono i bambini, che non avevamo
mai utilizzato una web cam,
ad insegnare alle loro maestre
come si andava su internet
e cosa si poteva fare su internet.
Potete immaginare, poi,
i problemi annessi e connessi.
Dovemmo, difatti, quell'anno,
organizzare dei corsi
all'Università della Terza Età ,
venivano anche alcune maestre,
perché poi gli insegnavamo
cosa si poteva fare con un computer
e cosa si poteva fare con internet.
Questa fu un'esperienza interessante
che ebbe poi un corollario carino,
perché con la nostra stessa tecnologia
ci venne chiesto di realizzare
la copertura wireless integrale
del Museo del Cinema,
che è ospitato
nella Mole Antonelliana a Torino
e fu il primo museo
completamente coperto da Wi-Fi
nella zona del torinese.
Ovviamente adesso ci sono
altri sistemi molto più sofisticati,
non quelle scasserie
che avevamo montato all'inizio;
però comunque l'idea è
che anche un progetto complesso -
che poi funzionò anche molto bene,
facevano didattica a distanza -
lo si poteva fare
anche con tecnologia povera,
ovviamente però con il know-how adeguato.
Sulla scorta di questi primi esperimenti,
io fui contattato, tra la fine del 2006
e l'inizio del 2007, da alcune ONG;
una, in particolare voleva utilizzare
in Africa i nostri sistemi,
però li incontrai alcune volte,
mi dissero che era carino, interessante,
fate delle cose belle;
però secondo noi non funzionano,
perché una volta che le dobbiamo portare
in Africa non andranno,
perché il clima è diverso,
le condizioni ambientali sono diverse,
le distanze sono più grandi delle vostre;
e quindi scelsero di allestire,
su quel progetto
sul quale stavano lavorando,
una connettività di tipo satellitare.
Quel satellite funzionò qualche mese,
poi fu così complesso il fatto
di collegarsi al satellite
che nessuno, sul posto,
lo sapeva aggiustare, modificare,
cambiare le configurazioni;
e quindi, l'esperimento
e il progetto finì.
Per dimostrare che i nostri cosi
non andavano bene solo
a Verrua Savoia e dintorni
ma anche più lontano,
decidemmo di partecipare
ad una competizione
e in particolare -
la buttammo lì un po',
come si dice, da sboroni,
però fortunatamente andò bene perché
decidemmo di realizzare il collegamento
via wireless con tecnologia povera
più lungo che non fosse mai
stato tentato fino a quel momento,
300 chilometri, collegando le Alpi
con gli appennini.
Ci mettiamo a lavorare su questa cosa,
strutturiamo tutta una rete
che doveva attraversare le Alpi,
andare dal Politecnico di Torino,
passare ovviamente da Verrua Savoia,
salire sulla Capanna Margherita
sul monte Rosa,
in questo posto bellissimo
che vedete rappresentato qua,
a 4.556 metri sul livello del mare;
e poi da lì doveva continuare,
arrivare negli Appennini,
andare in Austria.
Io sono uno sciatore,
quindi tutti questi posti erano scelti
in modo che ci fosse
una località sciistica nelle vicinanze.
Ovviamente lo stesso principio,
quindi montare della roba
che però doveva dimostrare
di poter essere fatta con semplicità ,
di poter durare
a condizioni quasi estreme,
però essere montata con componenti
che dovevano costare poco.
Ci mettemmo in laboratorio,
costruimmo delle cose.
Quell'immagine che vedete sulla sinistra
fu ripresa addirittura
dai quotidiani nazionali,
su Repubblica le mani di Riccardo,
che è il mio co-founder del laboratorio,
girarono in tutto il pianeta
senza nessuno che sapesse di chi fossero.
Quello è invece un momento
in cui stavamo montando
uno dei trasmettitori,
utilizzando la carta stagnola
per proteggerlo,
che avevamo recuperato
nel ristorante del rifugio.
Ovviamente non fu l'unico episodio
di montaggio in condizioni al limite.
Quello sono io che sto portando
un pezzo di antenna in seggiovia.
Quelle sono le guide alpine
che si stavano quasi immolando
pur di piantare un'antenna
sul balcone del rifugio;
e questo sono ancora io, che mentre loro
stavano rischiando la vita -
vedete gli scarponi da sci -
però comunque stavo programmando
un trasmettitore
appollaiato su una sedia,
praticamente a ridosso del balcone stesso.
Questo è un momento molto carino,
perché quando accendemmo
il primo hotspot Wi-Fi,
all'interno del rifugio,
e fu l'hot spot più alto d'Europa
perché ovviamente nessuno
ci poteva superare -
il Monte Rosa è la terza vetta
d'Europa,
quindi c'era poco da fare -
Però noi eravamo sulla seconda
del Monte Rosa, quindi la terza,
e coniammo un motto che divenne
uno dei nostri motti,
perché riuscimmo a realizzare
un collegamento a 300 chilometri,
portando una banda notevole, 30 Mbit,
e alla fine spendemmo
poco più di tre euro,
già il biglietto della seggiovia costava
di più, però comunque non tanto di più.
Avevamo i numeri per dimostrare
che si poteva fare qualcosa
in condizioni estreme.
Nel 2008 partecipiamo ad un bando
della "Banca Interamericana
per lo Sviluppo" di Washington,
presentiamo un progetto per realizzare
una rete Internet in Amazzonia.
80 progetti presentati, lo vinciamo.
Adesso il problema era
che bisognava andarci, in Amazzonia;
e bisognava anche dimostrare
che eravamo in grado
di far lavorare gli autoctoni
e anche trasferire loro
il nostro contenuto tecnologico.
Visto che mi avevano criticato,
mi avevano detto tanto:
"Bravi, andate voi,
finché andate voi funziona!"
Allora io non ci andai,
presi degli studenti
appena diplomati, laureati
e mandai solo loro,
per dimostrare che gli autoctoni
potevano essere formati da gente
con competenze che non derivassero
da anni e anni di esperienza.
La zona era questa,
è la zona di Puerto Francisco
de Aureliana,
che è sul fiume Coca.
Il villaggio dove andammo a lavorare
è il villaggio di Dayuma,
che è rappresentato sulla destra lì.
Questo è un momento
in cui stavamo montando,
nel pieno della foresta, un trasmettitore.
Forse non lo vedete bene,
ma comunque sono tutti autoctoni,
sono tutte persone del posto;
e questo è un momento
in cui uno dei miei studenti,
che poi, sulla scorta di quel lavoro,
trovò, in realtà,
occupazione in un buon ente,
quindi diciamo gli valse
anche un titolo di merito,
in cui stava formando, appunto,
le persone del posto.
Devo dirvi che questa è un'immagine
che porto sempre ad esempio
e che è una di quelle
che mi danno soddisfazione:
Dayuma, scuola di Dayuma prima,
scuola di Dayuma dopo.
(Applausi)
Non applaudite troppo
perché sennò poi mi tocca troncare.
Nel 2009 decidemmo di passare
a qualcosa che aveva a che fare
con un contenuto tecnologico
non solo di tipo software,
ma anche di tipo hardware
un po' più rilevante,
per cui partecipammo ad un altro bando,
questa volta dello stato del Quatar,
che aveva proposto dei finanziamenti
ad enti di ricerca
che avessero delle idee
un po' particolari, un po' interessanti.
Io avevo proposto un'idea
alla Regione Piemonte,
che venne bocciatissima,
che era quella di sviluppare una sonda
che doveva viaggiare nei tubi,
analizzare i rumori fatti
dall'acqua dei tubi
e tramite onde radio riportare
l'informazione alla superficie,
perché in Italia il 50 percento
dell'acqua che viene presa alla sorgente
viene persa prima di arrivare
al destinatario, che siete voi:
il 50 percento.
È solo acqua, ma produrre l'acqua costa.
In Italia non glien'è fregato tanto,
però in Quatar sì.
Ci finanziano questo progetto,
tre anni di finanziamento,
un finanziamento adeguato
e questo è il risultato,
che venne presentato
a dicembre dell'anno scorso,
è il Water Mall, talpa d'acqua,
è questo oggetto che naviga nei tubi
e trova le perdite,
con una precisione di dieci centimetri,
risparmiando tantissimo tempo
per andare ad individuare le perdite
e anche per definirle,
quindi risparmiando poi sugli scavi,
su tutta una serie di cose
annesse e connesse.
Visto e considerato che andare in giro
per le montagne, per il pianeta ecc.
era interessante, ma comunque sia
"home sweet home", come si dice,
allora nel 2010 decidemmo di andare
a tornare a lavorare a Verrua Savoia,
questa volta non per aprire un hotspot,
ma per allestire un vero e proprio
campo sperimentale permanente,
dove tutti gli utenti, tutti i cittadini
potessero diventare utenti
di un nostro sistema
e dove noi ci saremmo potuti
mettere a giocare con questo sistema,
quindi sviluppare tecnologia,
tentare e analizzare
delle possibili forme di tecnologia
che potessero essere utili,
replicate in giro per il mondo,
ma soprattutto arrivare a costruire
delle vere e proprie reti organiche,
magari che permettessero di pensare
di coprire interi paesi.
L'esperimento fu accolto
con un successo incredibile;
va beh, regaliamo banda a tutti,
quindi potete immaginare.
Vedete quella foto sulla destra?
È una persona che in pieno inverno 2012,
quello rigidissimo,
andò da solo a ripulire i pannelli solari,
che sono rappresentati
in altro periodo sulla sinistra,
pur di riportare il segnale,
la connettività a tutto il comune.
Ci furono anche gli elementi divertenti.
Ad esempio, visto che lasciamo
che la tecnologia venga installata
e montata dai singoli cittadini
e c'è la gente che le posiziona
nei posti più strani;
adesso, a parte gli occhiali da sole,
c'era uno che riusciva, e lo premiammo,
a far funzionare la rete
nonostante tenesse
la sua antennina sulla sdraio.
Quello sulla destra ci ha provato,
a risparmiare i soldi
per comprarsi l'antenna,
assemblando quella specie
di lava-insalata con i rasoi,
ma in quel caso la parabola -
però lo abbiamo premiato lo stesso.
Qualcuno di voi che ha
dimestichezza con la tecnologia
sa che esiste Arduino.
Arduino è un progetto che prevede il fatto
di utilizzare piattaforme open hardware,
quindi di costo molto contenuto,
per realizzare tutta una serie di cose.
Nel 2011 abbiamo esteso questo discorso
del dare connettività ai miei concittadini
andando anche a portare dei dispositivi
che dovevano, in qualche modo,
semplificare la vita domestica,
quindi ad esempio realizzare
cose collegate ad Internet
che permettono, anche,
di monitorare le temperature;
fare assistenza, ad esempio,
all'irrigazione del terreno;
ma la cosa più importante
è una rete totalmente autonoma
ed indipendente,
che serve all'assistenza
domestica agli anziani,
senza la necessità di essere collegati
ad un telefonino,
alla rete telefonica tradizionale,
solo con copertura ad onde radio
in tutto il paese, con un costo irrisorio.
Stiamo parlando di un comune
che dà queste condizioni
di servizio di assistenza
con una stazione radio base
che costa la bellezza di 15 euro.
Nel 2012, sulla scorta
dei nuovi esperimenti a Verrua,
insieme con la Quatar University
vinciamo un'altra cosa
che ci porta in Africa,
nelle Isole Comore,
arcipelago nell'Oceano Indiano,
uno degli Stati più poveri del pianeta;
e lì andiamo:
vedete, delle condizioni -
potete avere delle situazioni
in cui le strade sono
drammaticamente interrotte -
mettiamo insieme un'accozzaglia di gente
tra qatarini, cubani, io ecc. ecc.,
ci divertiamo per circa tre mesi
e in quei tre mesi
andiamo a costruire delle cose
che permettono la copertura integrale
di Internet di tutto il territorio.
Passiamo da una situazione
in cui voi andate in giro per la giungla,
e trovate, magari, un telefono
messo così nell'ambito del nulla,
a una situazione
in cui avete sempre l'hotspot -
quella è la realizzazione
a cui tengo di più -
all'interno di una palma sulla destra.
2013.
Torniamo di nuovo in Italia,
ci mettiamo a lavorare
su tutta una serie di cose
e questo in assoluto è l'oggetto
a cui io tengo di più ultimamente.
Questa è una telecamera
che monta lo stesso sistema
di trasmissione
che è stato usato per fare
i 300 chilometri, per l'Africa ecc.;
questo sta all'interno di un vigneto.
Questo mi permette di controllare
le condizioni di vita,
di evoluzione delle piante;
e mi permette di evitare
l'utilizzo di roba chimica, di pesticidi;
e di minimizzare, anche,
l'utilizzo dello zolfo e del rame,
quindi a favore
dell'agricoltura sostenibile.
Questo oggetto ha la capacità
di raccogliere informazioni su un range,
ovviamente 300 chilometri
magari questo non lo fa,
con un costo che è bassissimo;
e adesso abbiamo in previsione di portarlo
non solo nelle vigne del Piemonte,
ma anche in quelle del Chianti.
(Applausi)